[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña juan calero jefe de sistemas de
vehículos comerciales para astronautas
de la nasa y hablaremos de la misión q
one de la nasa y la compañía spacex que
si todo sale como se prevé se lanzará
este fin de semana a la estación
espacial internacional gracias señor
calero por acompañarnos se podría decir
que esta es la primera misión de
tripulación comercial que se lanza al
espacio
bueno la primera
emisión en general porque tuvimos una
una misión de dos astronautas que eran
una misión para ver si el sistema
trabajaba bien eso puede hacer unos
meses este año y todo trabajo bien y
entonces ahora vamos a entrar a una
etapa nueva donde vamos a empezar a
lanzar atronadora 4 en esta edición
mañana y tenemos mucho más planeado para
el futuro
señor calero ya en mayo como usted nos
lo decía la nasa y spacex lanzaron la
dimos la primera misión que fue
calificada como histórica por múltiples
razones pero cómo cambiar a la misión
que iban los vuelos espaciales
tripulados
bueno vamos a empezar a trabajar con
compañías privadas estamos trabajando
ahora con empresas que van a lanzar
mañana estamos también trabajando con la
compañía point y antes nosotros hacíamos
gobierno la nasa con space ya lo y con
las misiones de la luna y el gobierno
diseñaba los en los equipos y los
cohetes pero ahora estamos dándole este
trabajo a las compañías privadas y ellos
están tienen unas ideas diferentes y
estamos trabajando bien cerca con ellos
para para poder tener un éxito y
mantener la seguridad de los astronautas
que para nosotros son como familia y es
lo que tenemos que asegurar que estén
bien seguros bueno y la tripulación de
cuatro personas estará en la estación
durante seis meses en la duración
estándar de una misión para los
astronautas
estándar el demo tuve que mencionarte
gente fue de dos semanas nada más que
era para ver si los sistemas trabajaban
pero generalmente son seis por alrededor
de seis meses y la cápsula está diseñada
para estar conectada a la estación por
más de 200 días pero hemos tenido
astronautas que se han pasado hasta 400
días en la estación viviendo más más de
un año
señor calero y que harán estos
astronautas cuando lleguen a la estación
espacial internacional cuál es su misión
bueno la misión de ello es bueno no
paran de trabajar ellos lo que hacen en
la estación es
duermen comen y trabajan tienen muchos
experimentos que estamos tratando de
aprenderlo cómo vamos a ir a la luna ya
marte cómo podemos obtener un viaje tan
largo así y también tienen tenemos
experimentos para ver si cómo podemos
curar las enfermedades que tenemos aquí
en la tierra y bueno como en cualquier
casa como los que pasan nuestra tienen
muy inodoro nuevo que van a cambiar y
están porque ya como que ya lleva a la
estación 20 años ahí arriba
ya es tiempo para cambiar el inodoro
le pregunto como allana el camino este
lanzamiento para los futuros
exploradores de la luna que vienen con
el programa artemis más adelante
bueno vamos estamos aprendiendo mucho
estamos aprendiendo cómo trabajar con
las compañías estás privadas y cuando
vamos a la luna vamos a trabajar con más
compañías privadas lo bueno de esto es
que
es que hay competición ahora con estas
compañías y esa competición hacen que
tenemos ideas nuevas
y estamos estudiando cómo hacen las
relaciones mejores cuando ya tengan
cuando ven el tiempo para ir a la luna
ya marte vamos estar bien preparados con
las compañías privadas y comerciales
para lograrlo lo que la nasa va a lograr
en ir a la luna ya marte señor calero y
muy brevemente cómo pueden seguir los
espectadores del lanzamiento bueno
pueden ir a más
nasa punto gov diagonal live y eso
empieza a las 3 y media de tiempo ahora
este de eeuu pues muchas gracias por
toda esta información a ustedes gracias
por acompañarnos
[Música]